depuis hier la foule s'empare de la
petite maison d'aimé césaire ils
viennent de toute la martinique
s'imprégnait des lieux où le grand homme
et sa famille vécurent d'un demi siècle
dans le public beaucoup de curiosité
mais aussi d'affection pour l'homme que
l'on a connu de près ou de loin pas
comme on dit la maison où est ce qu'ils
savent être invité ici dans cette maison
il ya le côté politique le grand homme
tout ce qu'il a fait pour nous cette
prise de conscience qu'il nous a
inculqué ça me fait quelque chose de
magique
c'est la preuve que je vais entrer c'est
c'est quelque chose de cultivant pour
moi est ce que tu te sens proche de ce
personnage
oui très très proches ça c'est la lettre
réponse du parti communiste assez
virulent d'ailleurs
on est vraiment au delà de nos
espérances
entre hier et aujourd'hui ça m'a parité
un temps continue je crois aujourd'hui
encore plus et on se rend compte que les
marques milka attendait vraiment de
pouvoir avoir cette maison il y avait
beaucoup de gens de redouter les voisins
qui sont tous venus pouvoir en tpu pour
refaire connaissance avec lui et sa
femme ont tous dit ça fait longtemps que
j'attendais ça pour l'instant la
fondation aimé césaire ne dispose que de
fonds privés et ce sont souvent des
bénévoles qui assurent les visites son
ancien jardinier son chauffeur clémence
son ancienne gouvernante si son bureau
très simplement
ils écrivent est un taux il était sur
son lit couché sur son île avait
toujours cahier à côté nuit il écrivait
exif onex il était dans sa voiture il
écrivait d'un sur la table à manger
pendant il est cruel dont je lis jamais
vu vraiment au 2e but du pied crie
jamais vu ça c'est vrai que les gens
sont ce soir les gens sont curieux et
c'est vrai qu'ils connaissent mieux c
est en tant que comme polycom public
mais ne savait pas comment ils vivaient
donc les gens se font 10 des films si
vous voulez de lait quand ils arrivent
ici ils sont surpris de voir comment ils
vivaient très simplement la maison
d'aimé césaire sera ainsi accessible
gratuitement au public tous les samedis
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
ensuite s'engage une période de travaux
et de mise aux normes d'ici deux ans la
fondation veut replanter ici les
caféiers le petit jardin créole original
et faire de ce site un lieu de création
et une résidence d'artistes